This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you grew up watching Warner Bros. cartoons and I really, really hope you did, you might remember seeing the words, directed by Chuck Jones in big letters in the opening credits. Chuck Jones worked for decades on cartoons like Looney Tunes from the 1930s until his death in 2002. In addition to being a director, he was also an animator. He gave Bugs Bunny that cocky slouch. He gave Daffy Duck those mischievous
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。如果你从小看华纳兄弟（Warner Bros.）的动画片长大——我真心、真心希望你看过——你可能还记得在片头字幕里看到“查克·琼斯（Chuck Jones）导演”这几个大字。从20世纪30年代直到2002年去世，查克·琼斯几十年来一直致力于制作像《乐一通》（Looney Tunes）这样的动画片。除了担任导演，他同时也是一名动画师。他赋予了兔八哥（Bugs Bunny）那种傲慢懒散的姿态，赋予了达菲鸭（Daffy Duck）那种淘气的
eyes. I think Bugs Bunny's bar mischievous Daffy Duck is insane. He made a mute, wily coyote, hold up signs that commented on the sad irony of his cartoon life. In 1996, Jones accepted an Academy Award for Lifetime Achievement. Well, I stand guilty before the world of directing over 300 cartoons the last 50 or 60 years. Hopefully, this means you've forgiven me. Chuck Jones is the name most people remember when they think about those cartoons. Hopefully, this means you forgiven me. Chuck Jones is the name most people remember when they think about those cartoons.
眼神。我觉得兔八哥那……淘气的达菲鸭太疯狂了。他让一只沉默寡言、狡猾的歪心狼（Wile E. Coyote）举起牌子，对它那充满悲剧讽刺意味的动画人生进行吐槽。1996年，琼斯荣获奥斯卡终身成就奖。“好吧，我因在过去50或60年里指导了300多部动画片而问心有愧。希望这意味着你们已经原谅了我。”查克·琼斯是大多数人在想起这些动画片时首先记住的名字。（重复音轨：希望这意味着你们已经原谅了我。查克·琼斯是大多数人在想起这些动画片时首先记住的名字。）
But I want to talk about another guy, an artist who worked with Chuck Jones, a guy who wasn't just important to Looney Tunes. He changed the entire art of animation. Yeah, the amazing thing about this guy is that he never drew bugs bunny or Elmer Futter or your 70 Samaritan those characters. He drew the backgrounds behind those characters. So if you think of like, you've ever seen Duck Dodgers in the 24th and a half century. Duck Dodgers in the 24th and a half century!
但我想聊聊另一个人，一个曾与查克·琼斯合作过的艺术家，一个对《乐一通》而言不仅意义重大的人。他改变了整个动画艺术。没错，关于这个人最神奇的地方在于，他从未画过兔八哥、艾尔默·福特（Elmer Fudd）或那些经典角色。他画的是这些角色身后的背景。所以如果你看过像《光荣的鸭子太空历险记》（Duck Dodgers in the 24th and a half century）这样的作品——《光荣的鸭子太空历险记》！
Ducky Duck lands on this weird futuristic planet. Or you know, the roadrunner cartoons that jagged bright abstract desert. That is the work of Maurice Noble. Here helping us tell this story is reporter Eric Milinski. Hey. Eric used to work in animation as a storyboard artist on the Rugrats and a couple of other cartoons for Nickelodeon. Yeah, late 90s or early 2000s.
达菲鸭降落在这个奇怪的未来主义星球上。或者你知道的，哔哔鸟（Road Runner）动画片里那种参差不齐、色彩明亮的抽象沙漠。那是莫里斯·诺布尔（Maurice Noble）的作品。今天协助我们讲述这个故事的是记者埃里克·米林斯基（Eric Milinsky）。嘿。埃里克过去曾在动画界工作，担任过尼克国际儿童频道（Nickelodeon）《淘气小兵兵》（Rugrats）和其他几部动画片的分镜画师。对，在90年代末或2000年代初。
So break down for us what the layout artist does in the whole animation process. All right, well, so today, like in a TV show, you would start out with a script, or in the case of looney tunes that probably that start drawing story sketches to figure out the gags, the camera angles and stuff. And then before the animation starts,
那么，请为我们剖析一下，在整个动画制作过程中，场景布局画师（layout artist）究竟做些什么？好的，嗯，所以现在，比如在制作一部电视节目时，你会从剧本开始；或者以《乐一通》为例，可能从开始绘制故事草图入手，来构思恶作剧、镜头角度等等。然后在动画开始制作之前，
the background designer or layout artist has the first crack at drawing this world. And those drawings are then later painted in by someone else, but a layout artist like Maurice Noble who is really accomplished would actually have a say in the color choices as well. And so this is actually really important. So imagine you're watching Cartoon, and the layout or the background is sometimes the first image that you see it just pops on screen for a second. And your brain needs to instantly register where you are and what mood you're supposed to feel.
背景设计师或场景布局画师会率先对这个世界进行构思绘制。这些画作随后会由其他人上色，但像莫里斯·诺布尔这样极具造诣的场景布局画师，实际上对色彩的选择也拥有发言权。这其实非常重要。所以想象一下，当你正在看一部动画片时，场景布局或背景往往是你看到的第一个画面，它在屏幕上一闪而过。而你的大脑需要瞬间识别出你身处何地，以及你应该感受到什么情绪。
So, like, you know, let's say you're watching a road on our cartoon, you cut to this big boulder that's perched on top of a really high narrow cliff. You're going to immediately feel dread for the coyote. So the layout artist is kind of like the straight man in the comedy duo, setting up the gag for the animator who gets to be, you know, the funnig guy. Right, and they don't get much credit. I mean, they're literally in the background. They're creating this painstaking work of art
所以，比如说，假设你正在看一部哔哔鸟的动画片，镜头切到一个立在极高、极窄悬崖顶上的巨大巨石。你马上就会为那只歪心狼感到揪心。因此，场景布局画师有点像是喜剧双人组里的“白脸”（一本正经的正常人），为负责搞笑的动画师铺陈包袱。没错，而且他们获得的赞誉并不多。我的意思是，他们字面意义上就处在背景之中。他们在进行极其细致的艺术创作，
before somebody else plops their drawings right on top of it. So you have to keep your ego in check. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Marie Snowball spent most of his career working for Warner Brothers, but he didn't start out to win, you know, wacky cartoons. As a young man, he wanted to be a fine artist, painting desert landscapes. When he graduated art school, Marie's found work at Walt Disney Studios. His first job was painting an apple, and he said it was a very tedious process, a very
然后别人直接把他们的画作盖在上面。所以你必须克制自己的自我（ego）。[♪ 片尾音乐响起 ♪] 莫里斯·诺布尔的大多数职业生涯都在华纳兄弟度过，但他一开始并不想创作那些疯狂搞笑的动画片。年轻时，他想成为一名纯美术艺术家，画沙漠风景。从艺术学校毕业后，莫里斯在华特迪士尼动画工作室（Walt Disney Studios）找到了工作。他的第一份工作是画一个苹果，他说这是一个非常枯燥的过程，
exacting process of just putting the colors down and grousing to match. He didn't think so at the moment, but it was definitely pampering him creatively. This is Bob McKinnon who wrote a biography of Maurice Noble. He says that even though Disney feature films that is really realistic and subtle backgrounds, you see every leaf on a tree or the shine on a door knob, Maurice felt like he was slumming it, squandering his talent on commercial art. In 1941, Disney Studios was torn apart by a strike. The artist wanted to create a union, and Walt took the walk out very, very personally.
一个极为严苛的过程，只需要填上颜色并不断调整以求相符。他当时并不觉得这有什么，但它绝对是在创意上磨炼着他。这位是为莫里斯·诺布尔写过传记的鲍勃·麦金农（Bob McKinnon）。他说，尽管迪士尼的长篇动画拥有非常写实且细腻的背景——你甚至能看到树上的每一片叶子或门把手上的反光，但莫里斯觉得这简直是在自降身价，是在把自己的才华浪费在商业美术上。1941年，迪士尼工作室爆发了一场罢工。艺术家们想要成立工会，而华特（Walt）对这场抗议非常、非常地往心里去。
When it was over, he got rid of anyone associated with the strike, including Maurice Noble. I think if the strike had not happened, he said he would have had a job for lifetime, it didn't he? I think he would have stayed there forever. But Maurice wasn't unemployed for long. World War II broke out and he was drafted into a unit that made propaganda films featuring a cartoon character named Private Snaffoo. We'll be trapped. Yeah, we still hailed shit up. I ain't no boob and I won't be trapped. Yeah.
罢工结束后，他开除了所有与罢工有关的人，包括莫里斯·诺布尔。我认为，如果那场罢工没有发生，他说过自己会有一份终身的工作，不是吗？我想他会永远留在那里的。但莫里斯并没有失业太久。第二次世界大战爆发了，他被征召入伍，进入了一个制作宣传片的部队，片中有一个名叫“二等兵斯纳福”（Private Snaffoo）的卡通角色。“我们会被困住的。”“没错，我们依然在坚守。”“我可不是个傻瓜，我才不会被困住。没错。”
As you can probably tell from that film clip, which has the very distinct voice of Mel Blank in it, the propaganda film crew was full of people from Warner Bros. including Chuck Jones. So I also talked with Todd Paulson, who's working on a book about Maurice's artwork, and he says Maurice found their style to be liberating. You know, everybody that was involved with those films for the army, definitely we're
正如你从那段带有梅尔·布兰科（Mel Blanc）标志性配音的电影剪辑中所听到的那样，这支宣传片制作团队里全都是来自华纳兄弟的人，其中包括查克·琼斯。因此，我还采访了托德·保尔森（Todd Paulson），他正在写一本关于莫里斯艺术作品的书，他说莫里斯发现他们的风格极具解放性。你知道的，所有参与那些军队影片的人，绝对都
able to finally express themselves. And then after the war, they got Marisa job working at Warner Brothers. He says, I was sweating, he said. No one knew how little he knew about that particular end of the business. And according to him, he was flying by the seat of his pants. I mean, he had done layouts before, but I mean, they were cranking out something like 30 short films per year. And just to give you a sense of how crazy that is. So today, you know, or at least when I worked in TV, you know, we would ship our storyboards to Korea.
终于能够表达自我了。战后，他们帮莫里斯在华纳兄弟找到了一份工作。他说：“我当时直冒汗。”他说没有人知道他对业务的那一端究竟有多陌生。据他所说，他当时完全是在即兴摸索。我的意思是，他以前虽然做过场景布局，但他们那时可是以每年大约30部短片的惊人速度在疯狂赶工。为了让你对这种疯狂程度有个概念：所以现在，你知道的，或者至少当我还在电视行业工作时，我们会把分镜脚本发往韩国。
Today, they would probably just, you know, email them to Korea where cheaper labor will fill in the animation or you could use a computer-based program like Flash to speed up the workflow. And that's just to make 22 episodes for a season. These guys are doing more work and doing it all by hand. Unlike that first painstakingly realistic apple that he painted for Disney, Marie Snowball comes to embrace the idea that backgrounds should be flatter and more cartoonish, more like the characters. Yeah, I mean like another example would be jungle book. I mean going back to Disney, it's one of my favorite movies because the animation
如今，他们可能只会把分镜发电子邮件给韩国，因为那里的劳动力更便宜，可以帮忙完成动画制作，或者你可以使用像Flash这样的基于计算机的程序来加快工作流程。而这仅仅是为了制作一季的22集动画。这些人要完成更多的工作，而且全部都是手工制作。与他为迪士尼画的第一颗 painstakingly realistic（极其逼真）的苹果不同，莫里斯·诺布尔开始接受这样一种观点：背景应该更加扁平、更具卡通感，就像那些角色一样。对，我的意思是，另一个例子是《森林王子》（Jungle Book）。回到迪士尼来看，这是我最喜欢的电影之一，因为它的动画
is totally amazing and it matches so beautifully the voices of those actors. But I've always been bothered by the fact that the characters are kind of flat and 2D, but the jungle is rounded with these subtle colors and lighting and the trees of three-dimensional shading, and I can never really suspend my disbelief that those characters are actually living in that world. And Marie Snowball felt the same way about Disney films. He always felt animation was a flat stylized medium, so he wanted the background to support that. The use of airbrush, he always felt the backgrounds that some other studios were fighting the characters, and people would come up to him and say, oh, you were inspired by Monet.
实在太惊人了，而且与那些演员的配音完美契合。但我一直感到困扰的是，角色们显得比较平面和二维，而丛林却是圆润的，带有微妙的色彩和光影，树木也有三维的阴影，我始终无法真正地说服自己相信那些角色真的生活在那个世界里。莫里斯·诺布尔对迪士尼电影也有同样的感受。他一直认为动画是一种扁平的、风格化的媒介，所以他希望背景能够为此服务。由于使用了喷笔（airbrush），他总觉得其他一些工作室的背景在和角色“打架”。人们会走到他面前说：“哦，你是受了莫奈（Monet）的启发吧？”
And this time he says, I don't think that way. He says, we're working in a completely new medium. This is a completely unique art form. And Marie-Sense of changing what Warner Brothers was doing because he's pushing the cartooniness of the backgrounds until they have the same sass as Bugs Bunny or the delusional insanity of Daffy Duck. Like in the Roadrunner cartoons, the coyotes reel and taginist isn't really the Roadrunner.
而这一次他说：“我才不这么想呢。”他说：“我们正处于一个全新的媒介中。这是一门完全独特的艺术形式。”莫里斯改变华纳兄弟传统做法的理念，体现在他不断推陈出新，强化背景的卡通感，直到它们拥有与兔八哥相同的俏皮劲儿，或是达菲鸭那种歇斯底里的疯狂。就像在《哔哔鸟》动画片中，歪心狼真正的对头其实并不是哔哔鸟，
It's the desert landscape and, you know, the Acme Corporation, which are conspiring to make his life miserable. The earlier Roadrunner cartoons that were done before he got there, there's a few of them. They're a little more realistic. They're a little more just straight ahead. And when he got there, he started to use all these different techniques. And as he went along, he would have what he called off registration colors, whether the lines of the rocks wouldn't line up with the color behind them.
而是沙漠风景，以及那些处心积虑想让他的生活陷入悲惨境地的“艾克米公司”（Acme Corporation）。早期的《哔哔鸟》动画片在他加入之前就制作了几部，它们的风格要现实一些，更加直白。而当他加入后，他开始运用各种不同的技巧。随着制作的推进，他使用了一种他称之为“错位色彩”（off registration colors）的手法，即岩石的线条与它们背后的颜色并不能完全对齐。
And he said that was to give you a heat shimmer. Which he knew all about because he grew up in New Mexico. He grew up in that kind of thing. He played in the rocks and he saw it. I'm sure all that influenced his take on the deserts when he did the roadrunner car to it. And this is how Maurice Noble becomes a hero to layout designers. Remember, his work is not supposed to detract from the characters. I mean, the layouts are supposed to support the animation and make it stand out. And he does that brilliantly, but he also develops
他说那是为了营造一种热浪摇曳的感觉。而他对这一点了如指掌，因为他是在新墨西哥州长大的。他就在那种环境中长大，在岩石间玩耍，并且亲眼见过。我确信，这一切都影响了他创作《哔哔鸟》动画片时对沙漠的理解。这就是莫里斯·诺布尔如何成为场景布局设计大师心中的英雄。记住，他的作品本不该喧宾夺主。我的意思是，场景布局本应衬托动画，让其大放异彩。他极为出色地做到了这一点，但他也发展出了一种
a unique and recognizable style. And it's almost like he built a stage for brilliantly, but he also develops a unique and recognizable style. And it's almost like he built a stage for a show, but the stage is winking at the audience. So I studied animation at Cal Arts, and so we'd be watching a cartoon like Duck Dodgers in the 24th and a half century. And we would burst out laughing because Daffy Duck had landed on Planet X and Marisa had drawn the clouds and the trees in the shape of giant X's. As Noble is coming into his own, he's starting to get co-director credit on some of the films, but Chuck Jones is still reaping most of the acclaim.
独特且极具辨识度的风格。这简直就像是他在为一场演出搭建舞台，而这个舞台却在向观众俏皮地眨眼。我在加州艺术学院（Cal Arts）学习过动画，所以我们会看像《光荣的鸭子太空历险记》这样的动画片。我们会突然放声大笑，因为达菲鸟降落在了X星球上，而莫里斯把云朵和树木都画成了巨大的“X”形。随着莫里斯逐渐迎来创作的成熟期，他开始在其中一些影片中获得联合导演的署名，但查克·琼斯依然收割了大部分的赞誉。
Todd Poulson, one of Maurice's predejiys, says that this became a point of tension between them in the 60s when they were working at MGM. It was a working relationship, and it became more and more strained as Chuck became more and more successful, especially in the 60s, and that came to a head when they made Dot in the line. The Dot in the line was an adaptation of a children's book. And it was about a dot that falls in love with a line and it's a story of their romance. Chuck Jones was the director on the short, but he was having trouble figuring out how to
莫里斯的门生之一托德·保尔森说，这成为了他们在60年代在米高梅（MGM）工作时两人之间产生紧张关系的一个导火索。这是一种工作关系，而且随着查克越来越成功，这种关系变得越来越紧张，尤其是在60年代。当他们制作《点与线》（The Dot and the Line）时，这种矛盾达到了顶峰。《点与线》改编自一本童书。
adapt it. So, the executives went to Maurice. He said, well, if you don't involve Chuck, I can make this work for you. And so Chuck brought the stuff in, threw it down on his desk, and stomped out, and Maurice wouldn't show him what he was working on. Once upon a time, there was a sensible straight line who was hopelessly in love with a dot.
讲的是一个点爱上了一条线的故事，这是一个关于他们浪漫史的故事。查克·琼斯是这部短片的导演，但他一直在为如何将其改编而感到头疼。于是，高管们找到了莫里斯。莫里斯说：“好吧，如果不让查克参与，我可以为你们把这个做好。”于是查克把资料拿来，重重地摔在桌子上，然后气冲冲地走了出去，而莫里斯压根不让他看自己在做些什么。从前，有一条循规蹈矩的直线，无可救药地爱上了一个点。
You're the beginning and the end, the hub, the core and the quintessence he told at Endley. But the frivolous dot wasn't a bit interested. For she only had eyes, for a wild and unkempt squiggle, who never seemed to have anything on his mind at all. It's a very charming film, but it's probably the most personal of all of Marisa's films because it's really, just him on the screen, it's pure graphics, there's no classic characters as you might think of them as just dots lines is purely abstract but really beautiful.
“你是起点与终点、枢纽、核心与精华，”他对它无休止地表白。但那个轻浮的点却一点也不感兴趣。因为她的眼里只有那个狂野、不修边幅的曲线条，他似乎满脑子都不知道在想些什么。这是一部非常迷人的电影，但它可能是莫里斯所有作品中最具个人色彩的一部，因为屏幕上真的只有他自己，这是纯粹的图形艺术，里面没有你通常所认为的经典角色，只有点和线，完全是抽象的，但真的很美。
The film is this pure distillation of Marisa's work and he's telling a story creating emotions and humor with just basic shapes and colors. But Chuck Jones still got director credit. And of course it won the Oscar but he said that Chuck didn't ever thank him. And Todd says that even though everyone knew it was Maurice's film, Maurice wasn't invited to the Oscars. So Chuck Jones and Maurice know what kept working together. They worked on how the Grinstall Christmas and a bunch of other Dr. Suce adaptations, but they fell out of touch for about 20 years until the early 1990s, when Warner Brothers reunited them to make cartoons that played before feature films. They hired a bunch of young artists
这部电影是莫里斯作品的纯粹提炼，他仅用基础的形状和色彩就在讲故事、创造情感和幽默。但查克·琼斯依然得到了导演署名。而且它理所当然地赢得了奥斯卡奖，但莫里斯说查克从来没有谢过他。托德说，尽管人人都知道这是莫里斯的电影，但莫里斯并没有被邀请去参加奥斯卡颁奖典礼。所以查克·琼斯和莫里斯·诺布尔继续合作。他们合作了《圣诞怪杰》（How the Grinch Stole Christmas!）以及其他一堆苏斯博士（Dr. Seuss）作品的改编，但他们失联了大约20年，直到20世纪90年代初，华纳兄弟让他们重新聚首，制作在长片电影前播放的动画短片。他们雇佣了一群刚从加州艺术学院毕业的年轻艺术家，
who just graduated from Cal Arts, and one of them was Scott Morse. Morse, no, but Morse, no, but where do I know that from? I was like, oh, it's because it was one of the names that preceded directed by Charles M. Jones on all of the cartoons that I grew up watching every day of my life. One of the first lessons that Scott learned
其中之一就是斯科特·莫斯（Scott Morse）。莫斯，诺布尔，但莫斯，诺布尔，我怎么会知道这个名字？我当时想，哦，那是因为它是陪伴我度过生命中每一天、我从小看到大的所有动画片里，在“查尔斯·M·琼斯导演”之前出现的名字之一。斯科特学到的第一课
was that Marisa's fantastic backgrounds were not just invented out of thin air. Marisa did a ton of research. Everything he exaggerated was based on something in the real world. You'd get an assignment like, oh, you know, Bugs Bunny's gonna be stuck on a desert island or a stuck on a jungle island.
就是，莫里斯那些光怪陆离的背景可不是凭空捏造出来的。莫里斯做了大量的调研。他夸张化的每一个细节，都是以现实世界中的事物为基础的。你会接到这样的任务：“哦，你知道的，兔八哥要被困在荒岛上了，或者被困在丛林岛上了。”
So there should be palm trees and it should be all this stuff. It's like, okay, great. And I'd come back with the drawing and he'd be like, what is this? And I'm like, are there palm trees? And he's like, those are stuckas. What were you looking at? It's like, well, there's a palm tree right out the window.
“所以这里应该有棕榈树，应该有所有这些东西。”这就像是，好的，太棒了。然后我拿着画作回来，他会说：“这是什么？”而我说：“难道这不是棕榈树吗？”他说：“那是苏铁（stuckas / cycads）。你当时到底在看什么？”我说：“好吧，窗外就有一棵棕榈树啊。”
He's like, that's a stucka. You gotta learn your trees. But Marisa wasn't really that gruff. After work, he talked to these 22 year old animators like he was just one of the guys. He'd be like, let's go to the baseball game. Let's go do this other thing. You know, we should go to a museum.
他说：“那是苏铁。你得把树认清楚。”但莫里斯其实并没有那么粗鲁。下班后，他跟这些22岁的动画师聊天时，就像他们当中的一员一样。他会说：“我们去看棒球比赛吧。我们去干点别的什么。”“你知道的，我们应该去一趟博物馆。”
Pretty soon you realize he's more like your grandpa who is just a really cool guy to hang out with. So Scott Morrison, the script of artists, became known as the Noble Boys. And Maurice pushed them to develop their own style, but his sensibility really seeped into their work. Like Scott is at Pixar now, which is the home of 3D animation, which we think is the complete opposite of, you know, the flat landscapes of Looney Tunes. But you can really see Marisa's influence on the Pixar films if you look for it. Like the film up. Think about that house carried by a massive amount of balloons, and lands on the very
很快你就会发现，他更像是你的爷爷，是一个非常酷、特别适合一起消磨时光的人。于是斯科特·莫斯和这群分镜画师被称为“诺布尔小子”（The Noble Boys）。莫里斯敦促他们发展自己的风格，但他的审美确实渗透到了他们的作品中。比如斯科特现在在皮克斯（Pixar），那是3D动画的大本营，在我们看来，这与《乐一通》扁平的风景完全是两个极端。但如果你仔细寻找，真的能在皮克斯的电影中看到莫里斯的影响。比如电影《飞屋环游记》（Up）。想想那座被大量气球带着飞行、最后降落在悬崖边缘的房子。
edge of a cliff. Or in Wally, this cute little robot is scooting around these big menacing towers of garbage. You know, those are layouts that make you smile. That's classic marise. In May of 2001, the noble boys were reunited one last time. We all got, you know, the call of the Maurice. He was in hospice basically at home. It was just natural causes that he, that he was dying of. And he was pretty sure, everybody's pretty sure that that night was going to maybe be the last night.
或者在《机器人总动员》（WALL-E）中，这个可爱的机器人绕着那些庞大而充满威胁的垃圾高塔四处穿梭。你知道的，那些都是能让你会心一笑的场景布局。那是经典的莫里斯风格。2001年5月，“诺布尔小子”们最后一次聚到了一起。“我们所有人都接到了莫里斯的召唤。”他当时基本上是在家中接受临终关怀。他得的其实就是自然衰老导致的疾病，生命正在走向尽头。而且他很确定，大家也都确信，那一晚可能就是最后的时刻了。
So we all came over and hung out with him. And Chuck Jones did call that night. I remember being in the room with Maurice and somebody brought in the phone, I was like, Chuck's on the phone. And Maurice was like, OK, I'll talk to him. And we all knew for a fact that they hadn't really talked for months, if not a couple of years at that point.
于是我们都赶过去陪着他。查克·琼斯在那天晚上确实打来了电话。我记得自己当时正和莫里斯待在房间里，有人把电话拿进来，我说：“查克在电话里。”莫里斯说：“好的，我跟他说。”而我们都知道事实是，当时他们已经好几个月、甚至好几年没有真正说过话了。
And I just heard Mori's side of the conversation, but you know, you could definitely tell that they were, they had put everything behind them and they were friends, you know, and it was nice. And I, again, I don't know exactly what Chuck said on the other end of that line, but it was a very sweet moment to be able to see that, and know that people could go through a lot together in life and still have respect for each other, you know, up to the last minute and kind of celebrate what they had created together. To some extent, Marisa the Noble Boys is his real legacy.
我只听到了莫里斯在对话中的那一头，但你可以清楚地听出，他们已经把一切都抛在脑后了，他们还是朋友，那感觉真好。再次声明，我不知道查克在电话那头具体说了什么，但能够看到这一幕，并且知道人们在生活中可以经历那么多的风雨，却依然能在最后一刻保持对彼此的尊重，并庆祝他们共同创造的成果，这是一个非常温馨的时刻。从某种程度上说，“诺布尔小子”们就是莫里斯真正的遗产。
He was proud of the fact that they had blossomed into well-rounded artists. If Maurice could leave behind this idea in other people to do their own thing, we would never be in the background like he was. But it was a beautiful, beautiful background. I actually met Marie's number once. Oh yeah? Yeah. I went to Cal Arts and he came into our class
他为他们成长为全面发展的艺术家而感到自豪。如果莫里斯能在其他人心中留下这种坚持自我风格的理念，那么他自己哪怕永远退居幕后，也值了。但他留下的背景是如此美丽，无与伦比。我其实见过一次莫里斯·诺布尔。哦，是吗？对。我去加州艺术学院念书时，他来过我们班上，
on it, it was like a Monday night. And I had happened to have gone to the opera the day before on the weekend. And I was thinking about how often those guys made fun of opera in their cartoons. And I asked him, did you guys actually go to the opera regularly? Or were you just kind of making fun of it as a sort of you know high flutant cultural institution and he asked me what opera did you see and I said La Traviata and he said ah Velletta her death is beautiful and that is a man who knew a good death when he saw it.
那是某个周一的晚上。我刚好在前一天的周末去看了歌剧。我当时在想，这群家伙在他们的动画片里拿歌剧开玩笑的频率到底有多高。于是我问他：“你们当时是真的经常去看歌剧吗？还是说你们只是把它当成某种矫揉造作的文化机构来开玩笑？”他反问我：“你看了哪部歌剧？”我说《茶花女》（La Traviata）。他说：“啊，维奥莱塔（Violetta），她的死真美。”那真是一个懂得欣赏好死法的妙人。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Eric Molinsky with Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, but right now we have Marie Snowball layouts, the dot in the line short film and the strikingly politically incorrect private snafu. It's really of its time.
本周的《99% Invisible》由埃里克·米林斯基（Eric Molinsky）与萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会（American Institute of Architects）的一个项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我在 Twitter 上的账号是 @Roman Mars。但现在，我们有莫里斯·诺布尔的场景布局、短片《点与线》以及那部极具政治不正确色彩的《二等兵斯纳福》。它真的极具时代特色。
At 99%invisible.org Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
登录 99%invisible.org 了解详情。本节目由 RadioPublic 提供，来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。